[Musik]
hey leute und da haben es gibt auch
geräte können heute waren mittelstand
und ich setze ich muss immer an hamza
denken wenn ich das wort familie stand
irgendwo lese immer an dich haben
warum also wir haben jetzt zusammen das
abi gemacht und vor der schule haben wir
uns damit der clique getroffen in am
bochumer hauptbahnhof
aber da gab es mal eine bäckerei die
diese vanille stadt und haben sich jeden
morgen können wenn er nicht gerade zu
spät kam
jeden morgen gönnen und ich habe mir ein
dickes großes schweineohr gegönnt hat
schon echt also am morgen so ungesund
egal
na ja auf jeden fall machen wir die
heute und die sind ja auch wirklich sehr
sehr groß und ich mache ja auch genau so
wie in der bäckerei und wissenschaft mir
aufgefallen ist die gibt es gar nicht
das ganze jahr über ist erst mal
aufgefallen also und teilweise gibt es
ein paar monaten ist es kommt auch auf
die bäckerei wir machen jetzt ein
hefeteig bin zeige ich euch jetzt hier
sind die zutaten die wir dafür benötigen
ich habe hier milch die sollte lauwarm
sein dann vermischt sich das alles
besser dann habe ich hier ganz normale
standard mail neutrales öle habe ich so
einen bummel genommen so kam natürlich
etwas trockenhefe ihr könnt auch frische
nehmen ganz ganz wichtig vanille extrakt
bei diesem rezept und ein anteil des
mehls einfach mal weg nehmen dann könnt
ihr das später viel besser einschätzen
wann der teig wirklich fertig ist und
jetzt gebe ich hier alle zutaten rein
und verknetet
[Musik]
den hefeteig jetzt noch mal vier bis
fünf minuten auf der arbeitsfläche
kneten und gibt nur soviel dazu bis der
teig wirklich gerade so nicht mehr klebt
denn ihr wisst ja aber nicht stand so
richtig schön fluffig und genau so
werden unsere aufwendige alles beachtet
ich werde das jetzt hier nur noch ganz
kurz zu einer kugel formen und dann muss
nämlich der teig gehen für 60 minuten
das macht ihr so inniglich einfach eure
schüssel also die gleiche muster weniger
spiel gibt da etwas mehr untendrunter
die talk google da rein
ein bisschen noch mal um drauf damit
auch gleich nicht austrocknet und dann
einfach ein tuch darüber legen und dann
werden wir uns in 60 minuten oder was
ihm jetzt gerade überlegt ab lasst uns
doch den vanillepudding gene
zwischenzeit machen dann kann man
nämlich zwischenzeiten auf nutzen also
ist gleich und für die vanille füllung
benötigen wir milch außerdem
vanillepudding pulver zucker zu süßen
und vanille extrakt also ich mache
meinen vanillepudding gerne selber
allerdings braucht man dafür mehrere
eigelbe und daher denke ich mir bei
manchen rezepten kann man darauf
verzichten und auf puddingpulver
zurückgreifen allerdings ist mir das
nicht mal nämlich genug also ich
schmeckt natürlich sehr gut aber ich
finde für vanille stand muss nochmals
extra kick gegeben und da helfen wir uns
einfach mit vanille extrakt ihr könnte
zum beispiel auch wenn die zocker
er ist aber nicht so intensiv und tut
mir nur eingefallen verzichtet auf
vanillinzucker wald der wird mit
künstlichen angereichert und das
schmeckt man dann auch raus also das
schmeckt dann nicht mehr so natürlich
daher habe ich immer ganz gerne wenn
ihre extrakte findet ihr auch bei mir im
shop der ist alkoholfrei verlinke ich
euch genauso wie alle mengenangaben zu
diesem rezept in der infobox soll jetzt
gebe ich alle zutaten zu milch verrührt
das und dann wird der herd eingeschaltet
[Musik]
sobald euer von linde problem dann
einmal aufkocht merkt er dass er einen
weg daher ständig rühren damit doch am
topfboden nicht anbrennt dann einmal
umfüllen in eine schüssel damit er auch
schön abkühlen kann
und unbedingt auch die oberfläche
frischhaltefolie geben dann kann sich
auch keine haut bilden und ich warte
jetzt nur noch auf den hefeteig und dann
zeige ich euch wie es weitergeht so
jetzt ist die g 20 und der talk hat sich
schon verdreifacht und mich neben dem
netz einmal aus der schüssel oder müssen
wir ihn gleichmäßig große stücke
aufteilen und nochmal zu kugeln rollen
und ich sage euch dann wie viel gramm
meine tycoon jeweils liegen
[Musik]
also ich habe jetzt ungefähr 80 bis 85
gramm hier kugel genommen und ich habe
acht kugeln und aus bekommt es heißt ja
später acht leckere vanille stand und
jetzt nur acht ist doch in ordnung
wir sind nur zu zweit das ist dir da ist
vier und unterstützt man nicht in den
familien hortgruppe dass der vanille
stand gemacht haben
also wird sie nochmal kugeln geformt und
gibt jetzt noch mal unter eindruck ich
will einfach nur dass der teig sich
entspannt damit man später besser aus
rollen kann
es gibt jetzt auch nur für zehn minuten
unter einem tuch und danach geht auch
schon direkt weiter
[Musik]
und es sind ja jetzt keine hörnchen
sondern standen und vanille stangen sind
bei uns immer also eher länglich sag ich
mal könnt natürlich machen wie er möchte
das ist einfach nur optisch und
geschmacklich schmidt sowieso daher
nehme ich mir jetzt die kugel und
versuche so eine ganz grobe aber
abgerundete dreiecksform hinzukriegen
dafür nimmt euch einfach eure finger und
auch ein nudelholz sobald ihr dann diese
dreieckige form hinbekommen habt könnt
ihr euren pudding nach bedarf gerne noch
einmal kurz auf schlagen dann wird das
alles so ein bisschen geschmeidiger und
ich mache das jetzt so dass ich mir das
in meinen spritzbeutel füllen dann habe
ich überall gleichmäßig viel pudding und
kann das viel einfacher auf spritzen und
das macht ihr jetzt auf der breiten
seite und rollt das dann nur einmal
locker ein
[Musik]
also ich packe die vanille stangen jetzt
nicht alle auf ein blech sondern ihr
sollte sie schon mit viel abstand auf
dem blech ziehen und dann eine halbe
stunde noch einmal zugedeckt gehen
lassen damit der teig noch mal ein
bisschen flüssiger werden kann danach
bestraft ihr die oberfläche mit milch
auch hier könnt ihr wieder eine
pflanzliche alternative nehmen und dann
sagt ihr sie im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze ca 17
bis 20 minuten kommt immer auf den
backofen an
sie dürfen aber nicht zu dunkel werden
[Musik]
die erste firma dünne stangen sind jetzt
aus dem ofen und jetzt fehlt noch ein
entscheidender schritt das ist ganz ganz
wichtig wir nehmen uns jetzt
geschmolzene butter und bepinseln sie
damit und geben sie dann in zucker so
wälzen sie einfach nur das müsst ihr
machen also lange sie noch warm sind
lasst ihr euch fünf noten aus köln mit
durch die finger verbrennt und dann aber
wirklich weitermachen
[Musik]
so während die anderen ist auch im
backofen willst zeig ich euch schon mal
ein von ihnen auch wenn sie heißen ich
will die finger verbrennen für euch
mache ich das doch gerne so und ich sage
euch die sind so soft wie sie einfach
sein müssen job machen wir auf und es
muss genau so viel wandel kommt immer
drauf aber nur ohne raschen wir machen
jetzt das auto haben sie keine sorge
schnell damit wir das naschen körperlich
und euch auch entlasten und ihre katze
nach backen können also schaut in die
video beschreibung bestehen alle genauen
mengenangaben ich hallo geht's gut gab
kurzfristig muss ich darauf hinweisen
auch wenn ich jetzt so ganz kriege
finger ab hinterlasst uns darum wenn
euch dieses video gefallen hat
abonnieren nicht vergessen und aktiviert
doch gerne direkt die glocke dann seid
ihr immer top informiert wenn mein neues
video online kommt einfach nur genau
einfach mal leiten ihr müsst das läuten
jetzt haben sie das gesagt was mal die
lakers ist ja last gelegt damit ich auch
sehr gefällt euch und wenn ihr weitere
wie vom bäcker nachgemacht rezepte haben
möchtet dann gibt mir gerne scheint das
ist nämlich eine richtige reihe geworden
wie vor becker hatten schon so viele
rezepte naja gut also bis zum nächsten
mal meine süße ist nicht irgendwas
aufgefallen ich frag mich nicht ich frag
dich verliebt ist irgendetwas
aufgefallen bis hierhin vielleicht so an
meinem outfit oder so
nach klick ihr müsst euch vorstellen
also ich sage mir so meine schütze geht
ja nicht hier drüber ich habe kein
oberteil falsch rum aber wir müssen sind
vorstellbar
ihr müsst euch vorstellen für euch ist
das video jetzt vielleicht acht minuten
oder zehn minuten aber wir sind hier in
der küche stunden lang also es ist schon
draußen dunkel wir waren den ganzen tag
für diesen drehende kriegt man nicht
aufgefallen
ja das ist ja mal entschuldigt aber echt
krass also egal
bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]